[Music]
on the 7th of October frontier held the
frontier Expo 2017 it took place at
Olympic Park in London with guest
speakers demo stations and streaming
booth and I was invited as a VIP by
frontier only one small hurdle for me to
take I'm currently studying in Japan
anyway of course I had to go obviously
since this video exists even if it's a
bit more than a month after the actual
event happened and because it was a rare
opportunity to make a ton of online
friends some even for the first time
like flex trans quick toaster and geek
ism as well as of course being an
amazing way to finally talk to the
developers again and try to convince
them of any certain rides it's a game
baby
and besides frontier paid for most of
the costs so with a bunch of overdue
homework I embarked on a ridiculous
jet like fuel journey for a weekend in
London and now because I didn't dare to
vlog much and who'd forgot to record
videos much of the time here's a bit of
a different retelling of some of the
experiences and my opinions instead with
the benefit of hindsight and I hope this
will also give a whole new perspective
on the events comparative videos by
others which have already been out for
quite some time now and maybe even a bit
of my perspective and planet coaster and
on the community in general alright so
if I can just avoid breaking my camera
for a little bit I arrived in London
just last evening and went but pretty
quickly after just completely crushing
my jet lag is actually a lot worse than
I expected I've only slept for four
hours so I'm very tired
so I'm very sorry if at any points doing
this I fall asleep or anything like that
but today will hopefully still be a
pretty good day there's not too much
going on but at the end of today after I
do a bit of a visit to the city try and
buy some fudge because there is some
European stuff that I really want to buy
over here that you can't get anywhere in
Japan since that's on my to-do list but
also that's at five I should be having a
tour through the expo groans and that is
what this video is mainly going to be
about not necessarily that single tour
but mostly the behind-the-scenes sort of
stuff the the atmosphere that you get in
general at the expo there's sort of
information that you can't get through
any of the other valuable information
channels that there will undoubtedly be
many of about the expo where you can
find all the exclusive information about
planet coaster Jurassic roll and that
stuff of course it's very important as
well but this video will mostly focus on
other stuff and trying to give a bit of
a picture of what the Expo is like for
the people who cannot visit the expo
because they're far away or any other
reason or for the people who have
visited the expo would want to see it
from a slightly different perspective so
yeah without further ado let's get into
the time-lapse
now the first day wasn't very exciting
at least not for me I just went shopping
together with @fo because most of the
people hadn't really arrived yet I had
an extra day as a bit of a buffer since
I was coming over from Tokyo and it was
actually pretty fun though we went to
the center of the city
I bought some fudge and got some posters
and we met up with flex trance and
showed him around the city for a bit
before we went off to the venue for a
quick tour of the expo grant now the
tour itself wasn't actually that much
but it was actually really amazing to
see all of the halls being completely
empty before they would be so crowded at
the next day the tour basically showed
off the main parts of the venue and
especially the main hall for me with the
main stage and the demo stations looked
amazing at this time since the skill
really it was very impressive to see
with nobody in it so far plus the
Jurassic world corner had a spectacular
life-size Raptor and some nice quality
work work and foliage to boot so that
was pretty cool then we went back to the
hotel for dinner and honestly I just
crashed after that now on Saturday it
was time for the expo itself since it's
basically just a one-day Expo and I
don't have a lot of footage of this so I
recommend watching some other blocks
that I'll link in the description to get
an idea of what it was like in terms of
atmosphere but basically I had a pretty
varied schedule in the morning I would
start with the qawalli podcast with the
lady and Rudy as hosts which went kind
of like this so we are currently trying
to prepare for one of the worst prepared
responses that I've ever seen boots
around the area here and we're currently
trying to set up our equality over here
we have
yep oh all the way at the back ladies
liner Rudy who is currently trying to
test for mics we have dust builders who
is our saving grace today coming here
the guy with the gear bring back all the
microphones and in the back there with
curly hair is flicks pants as well run
around the corner stricto studio so
awesome planet Costa people in one group
over here Kings is over here we also
have the official koala beach as well
which is something that you can check
out when you're at the booth and you can
get one of the pike maps and see what's
in the party this was actually all done
designed and printed by Rudy and really
one of my favorite things that has come
out of koala Beach in general really
cool to see your own pie really makes it
feel a lot more real than actually in
hindsight though the podcast actually
went very smoothly it turned out to be
pretty lengthy and we had a bunch of
amazing depth on including fur Nick
Matthew and John I hope it's ok if I
call everybody by that first name so
we're really happy that we had so many
special guests that managed to make it a
bunch of awesome community members also
cheered us on as the audience so huge
thanks to them as well to be honest
though I'm just glad we managed to get
anything done at all after this I
promised that I would hang out in some
people screams so I stalked really the
lady and geek ism for a bit I think I
even distracted geek isn't so much that
he didn't manage to build a thing as
simple as an in-game hamburger so if you
see this I'm sorry about that and also
that's I checked out some of the talks
at the event which were quite
interesting so of course I managed to
make my way to the thrill engineers talk
and then I was having quite a bit of a
nerdgasm to see a speech about roller
coasters live on stage and I checked out
Johnny want to talk about frontier which
we talked about a bit day before and
finally I went to the talk my spoiler
Sam where he talks about you know many
spoilers
diesels
Oh
[Music]
no worries though he didn't actually
spoil anything that you buy now don't
know although I do have to say maybe he
did spoil some things when I had a
private discussion with him later on but
that's that's territory which I
definitely can't talk about now the rest
of the day was just a more scheduled
stuff like doing the quick sofa chats
for the events livestream and
hilariously failing to do a coherent
livestream on my own with lots of eating
and walking around and finally watching
the announcements in-between see what I
want to film each moment that the exact
moment that it goes through
Jurassic world instead of sangsu this
was also from when the Curious Case of
picnic benches happened I'm not sure how
much of a picture there is of this so
yeah so far but as soon as the picnic
benches were visible on the screen as
everybody was in the green room watching
the live stage and the announcement of
planet coaster the whole bunch of planet
coaster players in the green room just
started screaming like a crowd in a rap
battle it was absolutely ridiculous and
after the update was revealed people
visited the expo were honestly
noticeably more positive about mmm
people only what's the livestreams now I
guess this is in part due to the twitch
chat being as toxic as ever but I think
the hype of the crowd gets to you and
honestly there was also a lot of great
interaction between players and
developers on the expo and with the
deaths essentially walking around
without any formal schedule they were
pretty much free to talk with the
community all day which i think was an
eye-opener for both sides I would love
to see more of this kind of
communication
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now my final hours in London
the next day were actually some of my
favorite ones this is where I managed to
get like an hour in a half talk with Sam
Danny just standing outside the hotel
and he did live up to his name in the
act of spoiling a few upcoming features
which I can't talk about but what I can
say is that I was really happy to be
able to talk to him about the greatness
of swatch color pink coasters intamin
Blitzers mech and new gender comas I'm
not sure what effect it will have
he told me that their resources are
limited and the coasts of so far have
often taken months to make but at least
he took note of the ones I mentioned and
we actually have a lot of interesting
just funny coastering conversations
anyway and finally it was time to say
goodbye to all the amazing people which
I unfortunately meet just about twice a
year and head back to Japan to quickly
edit this video very quickly turn into
taking about a month to write the script
and everything anyway there you have it
it may not be as lucky as most other
people can manage to make their videos
but at least I hope you enjoyed hearing
my perspective on the events if you do
want to see a little bit more of my face
as well as someone actually talking into
a camera I can definitely recommend
watching the ladies on this video her
video is much better than mine should
give you a decent idea of the atmosphere
doing the events and honestly if you
can't get enough of it also check out
the vlogs of geek ISM flex trans and
strict toaster they're all really great
and give her a good compilation of the
many moments that happen throughout the
event and if you want to see the hotel
that we stayed at conflicting hurt
actually has a really cool sort of look
into it that especially me looking
backward was really cool to see and
finally I want to give a huge thank you
to frontier who not only made this event
possible but also nutmeats actually
attended seriously they did so much for
everybody it was incredible
anyway that's all for now thank you guys
for watching and I hope to see you
perhaps in the next vlog peace alright
now at the end of this video I want to
take a very quick off-script moments to
talk about my evidence hiatus from
Planet coaster then I'm sort of in right
now
even though I've uploaded a few videos
in the past two months
none of them were actually made while
I'm in Japan I haven't been able to even
make and finish a video here so first I
like to say I'm sorry about that I try
to prepare as much as I could for this
but honestly I don't really have enough
to show you guys at the moment I'm just
really sort of taking a break from
planet coaster I haven't really played
it in the last two months partly that's
because of me being in Tokyo trying to
get adjusted here and honestly also just
taking some of the free time that I do
have between my way to busy studying
schedule I'm trying to put that time
into exploring the city and the
surroundings as much as I can and then
some of the other free time I'm also
putting into parka texts which I'm
getting into again there's not much more
than I'll say about that
maybe you'll see some stuff pop up in
the future but I've been busy with that
quite a bit and to tell you the truth as
well I'm also sort of waiting for DM
diversity updates I'm definitely looking
forward to it especially the new freedom
with roller coasters and the new intamin
strata coaster I guess you could call it
even though probably people are gonna
use it much more flexibly like that
stuff like that is what I'm really
looking forward to so hopefully I'll be
kicking back into gear with planet
coaster at some points but yeah I just
wanted to let you know right now I'm in
Japan and I'm studying for those who
don't know that's actually maybe I
should have started with that right now
I'm in Japan and I'm here studying with
an exchange program so at some point
I'll be back in the Netherlands
hopefully have some more free time again
but for now I'm taking a little bit of a
break of planet coaster but hopefully
that break will also end pretty soon
anyway that's my life issues
oh no wait one more thing maybe I'll be
doing some vlogs of theme parks in Japan
I still have yet to sort of test the
waters in terms of how much people
actually want to see this and how good I
would actually be at doing it but it's
all of the theme parks around here are
high on my bucket list and very very few
of them are actually well covered on the
internet so I want to pick that up a
little bit
anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this and
hope you guys are happy to get a bit of
an updates I'm sorry for my lack of
uploads recently I'm trying to do
something about it anyway
see you guys